Logan for your career as a writer would
you be okay with a workload filled with
writing assignments for other projects
polishes rewrites Etc
and then maybe just do one or two more
feature scripts for yourself as long as
it meant that you were a writer
that you would be okay with that's what
what the daily duties were polishing
rewrites
you know coming in adding a scene here
and there for someone else
I feel like
if you're if you're in anything again
whatever the profession is so in this
case like if I'm a writer
what I should love first and foremost is
writing and then obviously people
diverge from that right and then they
have they have a lot of very specific
concerns depending on who you are as an
individual
um
but to me
to me the the love of the action
to me personally the love of the like
the activity sort of transcends
everything else
I think that sometimes the ACT
sometimes the activity can be a more
positive or negative experience right
depending on like
of all sorts of factors
um
but I like but to me if
there's the very like
the version that would make me like the
most happiest but if you're asking like
if I got to wake up every day and I got
paid to write would that like make me
happy like absolutely like
I think again my sort of like
perspective is is when you realize how
difficult
it is to sort of like
to manifest that not in not in these
sort of like new age way but to
literally like create that scenario
um
I I think that it makes you kind of just
really appreciative
um
that you get to have that experience
um
that's how it is for me anyway again
there are like I think there's
there's movies or stories that I'm
better at and there's certain like skill
sets that again are more unique to me
for whatever reason that is like that I
have a specialty in
um
but if I but regardless just the idea of
getting up and writing is I to me is a
wonderful situation to find yourself in
what types of stories are you best at do
you think
if someone came to hire you to do a
rewrite a Polish
it's a it is increasingly this sort of
uh
probably
I mean the sort of like
uh James Gunn like Taiko watiti
um sort of like camp
where
where it's these sort of like big sort
of genre even like sort of like these
genre Adventure pieces but with this
sort of like undercurrent of Comedy
um I've kind of accepted that that's
that that's what I do and it makes me
like happy to do it I think there's
always this idea where you're like oh
I'd like to do a Christopher Nolan movie
but I I I'm not Christopher Nolan you
know like I
when I'm doing a scene it needs to end
on a punch line and if it doesn't end on
a punch line I get like neurotic about
it you know I'm like no there has to be
what was the joke and it's like it
doesn't always have to have a joke
um but I think that that to me
I'm really like I'm really sort of glad
that like like I saw like a I saw the
new Suicide Squad like a couple weeks
ago
and I loved it and to me that's so
exciting because it's like oh okay this
is now this is a sub-genre right because
you have like these incredible people at
the top of their game who are help like
help shaping the conversation and you
can look at that and go like oh okay
like there there is a place for this now
I think the whole like the idea of uh
inclusivity and like diversity and all
those issues also like uh feed into that
same idea which is like when you can see
examples
of the stories you want to tell or the
skills that you think you have
um you know there's an opening for that
now and you're like okay people do like
that
um
it wasn't like this isn't just a me
thing right
um and so that's that's a I think that's
a cool thing that as
that as genre like keeps sort of like
diversifying into all these sort of like
um
there is a lot there's a much larger
Spectrum I feel like and that's exciting
because then you can look at that and
you can say like okay I think this is
where my voice fits in
um
and then hopefully and then hopefully
you could find a way to get there
because it's still very hard
um
what if someone asked you to to do a
rewrite on a an intense legal drama
feature film or a horror film that
there was no comedic elements too
I think the thing that like
this
previously I would like to get to a I
I'm not that person I should not be well
it depends on what it is but like but
intensely good legal drama no that
should not be me right
um and I and I think sometimes you're in
this weird position
where you're
um if you're not as established as you'd
like to be you sort of like
you take on things that are not the best
fit the goal is to try to get to a place
where
where you can turn it down because it
shouldn't be you for whatever reason it
shouldn't be you right because I think
that that doesn't do a service
to anyone
ultimately any sort of life story or
project or whatever should everyone
should want it to be the best version of
itself that it could possibly be
and if it's not the right fit for you
then it should go to whoever it's the
right fit for I think it's a disservice
to
to everything to try to like you know
to in that situation I guess sure okay
okay that makes sense that you feel that
your best self your best work would not
be suited for certain projects and just
knowing that you're okay with that and
that you do your best work you said sort
of these Adventure
films with the comedic twist that are
light maybe lighter I was it was
probably darker darker okay maybe this
is sorry there's some dark sarcasm yeah
interwoofing okay that sounds good yeah
the one thing I would add to that is I
do think that also
to me
to me uh it's sometimes less about genre
and more about the type of story right
because I also feel like sometimes
sometimes it's not I feel like any good
writer can figure out the conventions of
a drum of a of a genre and do that like
well
I think that it's harder to put yourself
in the position of characters that you
don't understand
and again I do think that a good writer
should have a lot of latitude and being
able to imagine that but I do think that
there are like there are just limits and
also with the other caveat being that
not only are there limits but also it's
not necessarily playing to your to your
strengths
right where it's like
if you know that you understand this
type of character
and
I I guess it hasn't really like come up
for me but if it was like illegal drama
but it was like oh it's a legal drama
like storing this type of person I go
like okay I do understand that better
um
and so maybe this makes sense to like
take a shot at sure like the TV show LA
law that had humor to it you know
whether it was dark sarcastic humor but
it wasn't this intense
um you know
sort of depressing drama it was later
and you know the characters had more
humor to them but yeah I I see what
you're saying yeah I was gonna like I
I have to take that like sort of
perspective because for instance on it
takes three like
I really enjoyed it
um
there's all sorts of other stories I
want to tell and I've been fortunate
that any opportunities that have come
since
people are able to look at the
characters and the tone
and say oh could you take that and could
you put it in this situation with like
the genre could be entirely different
um and that's and that's a really great
place to be because I don't think I
don't I think most people don't want to
sort of like only get stuck doing like
one type of uh one type of story
um or maybe some people do I I can't say
for everyone